donc on va commencer notre deuxième
audition de la journée de ce deuxième
jour d'ailleurs d'audition de notre
mission
flash sur les entreprises pétrolières
gazières et celle du transport maritime
qui ont réalisé des profits
exceptionnels pendant la crise merci
beaucoup madame directrice générale
Catherine McGregor merci beaucoup
Monsieur le Directeur Général Adjoint
Pierre-François rioletti d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en plus dans des délais
assez bref on présente cette explication
à l'ensemble des personnes que l'on
reçoit ce que l'on vous propose c'est
peut-être de commencer par un propos
introductif d'environ 5 minutes sur la
question qui nous préoccupe et qu'on
puisse ensuite avoir des questions et
des réponses de la part des différents
membres de la mission je vous laisse
donc la parole
très bien merci et merci bonjour à tous
messieurs les cours à porteurs mesdames
et messieurs les députés donc
effectivement je suis accompagnée de
Pierre-François qui est directeur
général adjoint en charme des finances
de la RSE et des achats et puis
également un de Julien Miro directeur
des relations parlementaires donc je
suis heureuse de d'être là aujourd'hui
avec Pierre-François effectivement parce
qu'il nous semble important pour nous de
participer à ce débat
nous comprenons le contexte de fortes
inquiétudes qui frappe les Français les
consommateurs les entreprises les
collectivités qui sont donc confrontés à
cette situation de la crise énergie avec
des prix effectivement très élevés nous
sommes bien sûr conscient de la gravité
des enjeux nous sommes en fait au cœur
du réacteur si j'ose dire et nous voyons
l'impact de la crise au quotidien avec
nos clients donc c'est vraiment un sujet
qui nous qui nous concerne au plus au
point je dirais en propos d'introduction
tout au long de cette crise qui a en
fait débuté il y a plus d'un an
maintenant on parle souvent de la guerre
en Ukraine comme point de départ en fait
la crise énergétique avait commencé à la
fin de l'été dernier
engie on a été extrêmement mobilisé sur
vraiment trois sujets premier sujet la
sécurité d'approvisionnement deuxième
sujet le coût de l'énergie et troisième
sujet quand même et malgré tout et
j'allais dire à cause de tout ça
accélérer la transition énergétique
donc un peu de contexte sur le groupe
pour pour vous rappeler nous sommes un
groupe international avec en fait une
présence en Europe mais surtout un
ancrage très fort une longue histoire en
France un certain d'entre vous vous ne
connaissez encore sous le nom de Gaz de
France nous avons l'état encore
actionnaire au groupe à hauteur d'à peu
près 24 % encore à ce jour nous avons
170000 collaborateurs dans le monde
78000 de ses collaborateurs en France
nous sommes bien sûr un acteur majeur
dans l'énergie nous sommes producteurs
d'électricité de plus en plus carbonée
ça on y reviendra en France nous sommes
le deuxième fournisseur d'électricité
mais surtout on est connu pour être le
premier fournisseur de gaz avec environ
40% de part de marché et quand je dis
fournisseur de gaz nous ne sommes pas
producteurs de gaz nous achetons du gaz
et nous le vendons nous achetons du gaz
au prix du marché et nous les vendons
également au prix du marché et puis nous
sommes au premier opérateur éolien et
solaire et j'espère qu'on pourra
reparler parce que c'est un sujet qui
nous tient fort à coeur nous avons
traditionnellement une forte culture de
service public cette culture elle est
portée par nos collaborateurs pendant le
covid ils l'ont démontré parce que ils
se sont assurés de ce service alors que
évidemment les conditions étaient très
très compliquées et puis c'est bien
illustré aussi avec le fait que nous
avons de nombreux contrats de
concessions avec par exemple la
Compagnie nationale du Rhône le CNR sur
nos opérations hydrauliques la chaîne
dans le midi près des Pyrénées et puis
les réseaux de chaleur la CPCU comme
exemple de concession et des actifs
régulés alors les actifs régulés dans le
transport de gaz avec notre filiales
GRTgaz la distribution GrDF les
terminaux métalliers les stockages c'est
important de réaliser ses actifs
réguliers on pourra peut-être parler un
petit peu de ce cadre réglementaire donc
la priorité stratégique pour NJ c'est
quoi c'est clairement d'accélérer la
transition énergétique en France et à
l'international et cette prior elle est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui depuis 2020
inscrite dans notre raison d'être
alors depuis le début de la crise
énergétique nos collaborateurs ont été
extrêmement mobilisés j'allais dire 24
heures sur 24 en particulier pour
assurer la sécurité d'approvisionnement
puisque vous savez il y avait quand même
une dépendance du gaz russe qu'il a
fallu bien sûr lever donc qu'est-ce
qu'on a fait on a travaillé sur la
diversification des sources
d'approvisionnement en travaillant avec
d'autres partenaires tels que la Norvège
l'Algérie les États-Unis nous avons
travaillé sur le remplissage des stocks
et dans les jours qui viennent on va
être à 100% en France qui est vraiment
une bonne nouvelle puisque on est en
avance de phase par rapport au début de
l'hiver donc c'est plutôt assez
rassurant par rapport au niveau des
stocks gaziers en France et tout ça en
contribuant de manière significative
significativement financièrement
pourquoi parce que nous avons par
exemple porter les stockages de gaz à
hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par rapport à l'année
dernière sur la même période donc ça
c'est un exemple de contribution entière
alors deuxième sujet la sécurité
d'approvisionnement c'était important on
a vraiment bien travaillé on est très
content de l'état de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement gaziaire aujourd'hui
à l'instant je vous parle en revanche à
notre sujet est vraiment compliqué c'est
le soutien des consommateurs des
entreprises et des collectivités face
aux problèmes absolument majeurs qui est
la hausse des prix de l'énergie
d'ailleurs nous dès le début de la crise
on a fait des propositions pour essayer
de modérer ces marchés de l'énergie en
disant il faut qu'au niveau européen un
plafond du prix de gaz soit mise en
place afin de modérer ces marchés à la
fois sur le gaz et sur l'électricité
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
débats européens n'ont pas beaucoup
avancé sur ce sujet c'est vraiment assez
compliqué d'aligner tous les acteurs
malheureusement nous avons également
pris des mesures qui sont plus disons à
notre main qui sont des mesures fortes
de protection des clients alors par le
biais du bouclier tarifaire gazier
décider par l'État mais comme vous le
savez sans doute nous avons fait des av
trésorerie importante pour le compte de
l'État à hauteur de 880 millions au 30
juin et pour le deuxième semestre on
sera sur des montants d'environ un
milliard d'euros donc c'est des montants
significatifs nous avons aussi pris des
mesures volontaires à la fin du mois de
juillet pour abonder le chèque énergie
avec des montants d'environ à 100 euros
une mesure qui va coûter à engie 90
millions d'euros et là on est vraiment
sur des mesures ciblées pour nos clients
vulnérables nous avons également mis en
place un fond de 60 millions pour aider
les PME pour contractualiser les
énergies et enfin nous avons doublé la
dotation du fond de solidarité de
logement qui permet aux collectivités
d'aider les foyers les plus amples qui
ont le besoin de plus pour pour les
aider avec leur prix d'énergie et on
continue en discrétion absolument
constante avec le gouvernement avec les
pouvoirs publics avec le régulateur
j'allais dire les régulateurs nos
contreparties bruxelloises pour trouver
des mesures honnêtement on n'a pas
toutes les solutions ce le défi du pré
l'énergie aujourd'hui on n'a pas toutes
les solutions en main mais on y
travaille parce qu'on sait bien que la
situation est très compliquée pour
beaucoup de nos parties prenantes
nous avons bien sûr une responsabilité
forte d'employeur en soutenant l'emploi
l'apprentissage le recrutement il
reviendra peut-être je vais pas
m'étendre parce que je sais que vous
voulez que je sois vrai nous sommes
également un groupe citoyen qui
contribue bien sûr au finances publiques
des États dans lequel nous opérons c'est
vrai également en France quelques
chiffres quand même pour placer le
paysage une contribution à hauteur de
2,9 milliards d'euros en titre des
prélèvements obligatoires en 2021 et là
je ne prends pas en compte les
prélèvements qui sont faits pour le
compte de l'État donc c'est vraiment les
prélèvements obligatoires pour le compte
d'engie
également des mécanismes bien sûr qui
fonctionnent bien pour capter une partie
des profits complémentaires qui sont
réalisés par exemple une redevance
hydraulique de la CNR et de la chaîne
qui capte 80% des recettes au-delà d'un
prix de 80 euros du mégawattheure donc
pour vous dire que le la redevance est
quand même assez efficace au premier
semestre 2021 cette redevance elle est
dehors de 100 millions d'euros et en
fait quand on regarde 2023 on sera
plutôt sur le 1 milliard d'euros donc on
a des dispositifs qui marchent assez
bien
alors le sujet de la commission je
comprends c'est bien de discuter le
profit des entreprises donc je vais dire
quelques mots sur ces profits pour engie
pour l'année 2022 nous avons eu
effectivement des résultats nets
récurrents d'environ 4 milliards d'euros
donc là je prends l'estimer qu'on a
donné au marché à la fin du mois de
juillet pour l'ensemble de l'année 2022
ce montant il est supérieur d'environ 1
milliard d'euros par rapport à l'année
dernière et cette augmentation elle
s'explique de la manière suivante trois
blocs à peu près équivalents
permettez-moi d'arrondir un peu pour un
tiers le redressement opérationnel de
nos opérations nucléaires ou Belgique où
nous avons 7 tranches nucléaires qui
sont aujourd'hui jouissent d'une
disponibilité importante un autre tiers
qui est lié à nos efforts pour accélérer
la transition énergétique donc là c'est
vraiment la mise en oeuvre de notre
stratégie ça veut dire quoi c'est la
mise en service de nouvelles capacités
et d'énergie renouvelable
qui contribue à l'amélioration de mes
résultats et également des efforts de
productivité puisque on a toujours du
travail à faire en tant qu'antonine
d'une entreprise comme engie et enfin un
tiers d'effet prix qui sont liés à la
gestion d'énergie et du risque pour le
compte de nos clients et de nos actifs
alors un point qui est très important
c'est que les profits que nous faisons
contribuent à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la nation
pourquoi parce que pour pouvoir être un
acteur sur un marché de l'énergie
aujourd'hui il faut avoir un bilan
solide et surtout il faut avoir des
liquidités je vous donne un petit
exemple la semaine dernière on attendait
un cargo de gaz naturel liquéfié qui
n'est pas arrivé on a dû aller
contracter les volumes correspondants
sur le marché ça nous a côté 80 millions
d'euros comme ça en une semaine pour
pouvoir opérer sur les marchés il y a un
mécanisme de garantie pour pouvoir être
opérateur sur ces marchés qui s'appelle
un appel de marge c'est un dispositif
qui est assez compliqué mais qui force
les acteurs qui opère sur ces marchés a
sorti du cash de la trésorerie de
manière significative et aujourd'hui
compte tenu des niveaux de volatilité et
des niveaux absolus de prix ces effets
de trésorerie j'allais dire presque
quotidienne s'élève à plusieurs
milliards d'euros par jour pour
certaines semaines ou les prix sont très
élevés donc tout ça pour illustrer le
fait que il faut avoir de la liquidité
et une solidité financière pour
aujourd'hui pouvoir faire ce qu'on fait
c'est à dire acheter du gaz le fournir à
nos clients stocker etc et j'ai parlé du
portage des stockage et bien sûr le
bouclier tarifaire avec des effets de
trésorerie important alors ce qui est
encore plus important bien sûr c'est
qu'est-ce que va faire enjid c'est
profits ces profits vont être investis
massivement pour accélérer la transition
énergétique pour vous donner une idée de
nos investissements en 2021 à 2023 on va
investir pour tout le groupe 30
milliards d'euros donc 30 milliards
la moitié de ces 30 milliards sont les
investissements de croissance qui sont
pour la plupart fléchés en faveur de
cette transition énergétique avec des
capacités éoliennes et Solières
additionnelles donc une partie bien sûr
en France et également gaz renouvelable
donc là on est plutôt sur le biométhane
on croit beaucoup au biométhane chez
engie et également l'hydrogène vert même
si on est un peu plus loin dans le
calendrier
et pourquoi est-ce critique pourquoi
est-ce critique de continuer d'investir
dans la transition énergétique parce que
la transition énergétique c'est pas
juste une réponse à l'urgence climatique
c'est également une réponse à la crise
aujourd'hui qui se présente à nous c'est
à dire une crise de souveraineté
énergétique de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et bien sûr de coût
de l'énergie et donc il faut développer
ces nouvelles capacités pour pouvoir
assurer cette énergie transit cette
transition énergétique qu'elle soit
abordable bien sûr bas carbone et
qu'elle assure la sécurité
d'approvisionnement dont on a tant
besoin aujourd'hui
je fais encore une petite parenthèse et
puis je m'arrête nous avons la vision
chez engie d'un mix énergétique
équilibré on pense vraiment que toutes
les énergies décarbonées ont leur place
je pense qu'il ne faut pas opposer les
énergies les unes aux autres c'est
important parce que quand on parle de
soleil d'éolien de biométhane chaque
élément va compter pour pouvoir avoir ce
mix énergétique équilibré qui va
vraiment être la source de résilience
dans le pays a beaucoup besoin et bien
sûr aux côtés du nucléaire ça va de soi
donc il ne faut pas freiner ces
investissements moi je pense qu'au
contraire on en est plutôt dans une un
besoin impératif de les accélérer avec
bien sûr le pendant de ça c'est bien les
mesures de sobriété qui vont être
importantes parce que c'est vraiment la
seule manière qu'on va avoir de résoudre
ce formidable défi et cette opportunité
de réussir la transition énergétique
voilà je m'arrête là et puis je pense
qu'on va pouvoir passer à la session
question-réponse merci beaucoup
merci merci pour ce propos introductif
alors vous l'avez dit le l'objet de la
mission c'est la question des super
profiers et de leurs éventuels taxation
donc je voudrais revenir un petit peu
sur les chiffres
vous avez dit tout à l'heure en
introduction l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie elle date pas uniquement de la
guerre en Ukraine elle a commencé avant
et notamment à la fin de l'été dernier
et dans le même temps dans votre propos
vous avez comparé les chiffres de cette
année au chiffre de l'année précédente
mais par cohérence il est donc évident
que l'augmentation des prix qu'on a
commencé à observer au milieu de l'année
dernière avait déjà un impact sur vos
résultats réalisés en 2021 c'est
pourquoi ma première question c'est
est-ce que vous avez une comparaison sur
une durée temporelle un peu plus
importante si on compare c'est les
chiffres que on a de notre côté et le
résultat net du groupe au premier
semestre 2022 c'était 5 milliards au 1er
semestre 2021 c'était milliards est-ce
qu'on peut avoir un regard qui remonte
un petit peu dans le temps
de mon côté j'ai fait ce travail si on
compare pas le résultat mais ce qu'on
appelle le taux de profitabilité c'est à
dire la capacité de votre entreprise à
générer des bénéfices au regard des
ventes si on compare l'année qui 2022
par comparaison avec la moyenne réalisée
entre 2015 et 2019 on obtient une
augmentation de ce taux de profitabilité
qui est passé de 4,1 à 11,6%. est-ce que
vous êtes en mesure aujourd'hui ou plus
tard de nous confirmer ces chiffres
première question deuxième question vous
avez dit
c'est profits réalisés c'est une force
pour nous parce que ça nous permet
d'avoir des liquidités et donc avoir des
liquidités c'est important pour pouvoir
parfois faire face à des situations
immédiates donc est-ce que à partir de
ce moment là vous pouvez nous préciser
sur les bénéfices réalisés sur les
profits réalisés quelle est la
pourcentage le pourcentage qui va en
trésorerie et comment était répartis de
manière générale les profits qui ont été
réalisés merci beaucoup
du coup du coup j'ai posé deux questions
complémentaires et puis je vous laisse
la parole vous deux questions qui
portent un peu sur la question des
mécanismes d'abord existant vous avez
évoqué dans le cas de l'hydraulique le
fait que les dispositifs de redevance
permettent d'ores et déjà à la puissance
publique à l'état de récupérer une
grande partie des recettes une fois que
celle-ci ou plus exactement une fois que
le prix de marché dépasse un prix
préalablement fixé on sait qu'il existe
un dispositif similaire dans lequel les
énergies renouvelables et je crois que
vous êtes d'ailleurs le leader sur le
marché français vous l'avez évoqué dans
votre dans votre propos introductif ma
question était donc de savoir quels sont
les prévisions dont vous disposez à la
fois au titre de l'année 2022 et puis
éventuellement au titre de l'année 2023
sur les restitutions de recettes qui
pourraient être opérées dans le cas de
de vos parcs éoliens et où solaire
deuxième question on a un débat qui naît
depuis une grosse semaine sur les
propositions qui ont été faites par la
Commission européenne qui porte
d'ailleurs sur deux volets le premier
étant un mécanisme consistant à
récupérer une partie des profits des
producteurs d'électricité ce qui peut
vous concerner à la fois au titre
d'ailleurs de vos activités françaises
mais surtout à mon avis au titre de vos
activités européennes je pense notamment
à celle que vous pouvez déployer en
Belgique et puis de l'autre l'idée d'une
contribution de solidarité dans le
secteur des énergies fossiles je voulais
donc savoir si vous disposiez au vu des
dispositifs existants d'une analyse de
ce que les propositions de la Commission
européenne permettrait de couvrir comme
assiette par rapport au dispositif
nationaux qui existent déjà
je vais je vais commencer par les deux
dernières questions puis je vais laisser
Pierre-François commenter un petit peu
sur la première question en particulier
sur les chiffres sur les chiffres passés
donc vous avez raison alors en fait je
vais peut-être commencer par la dernière
question parce que je pense que le votre
question sur les renouvelables elle
s'inscrit pas mal dans ce cadre en fait
et donc toute l'idée c'est de dire que
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez les
actifs qui produisent de l'électricité
il y a ceux qui produisent de
l'électricité à partir du gaz et qui
sont bien sûr en termes de profit
relativement squeezée puisque le gaz est
plutôt très cher et que en revanche les
actifs qui produisent de l'électricité à
partir soit du nucléaire soit de
l'énergie renouvelable ou autre source
qui n'est pas gazières ces actifs là ont
effectivement bénéficié d'un prix de
l'électricité élevée puisque il y a un
prix commun pour tous les actifs et avec
une base de coût finalement qui a
augmenté peut-être un petit peu pour des
effets d'inflation mais pas beaucoup et
en tout cas à la hauteur de ce qu'on a
vu sur les prix d'électricité et donc il
y a cette idée que certains de ces
actifs génèrent ce qu'on appelle une
rente infra marginale enfin c'est des
mots des mots un peu compliqués et pour
dire vraiment des profits qui ne sont
plus en regard des coûts que représente
cette production et donc c'est vraiment
l'idée de la mesure européenne qui est
une franchement une mesure quand vous
réfléchissez qui qui nous paraît nous
assez pertinents du point de vue
économique et finalement redistribution
de la valeur parce que on voit bien que
là il y a quand même un bénéfice dont
ces actifs n'avaient pas besoin avant et
qui voilà donc ça c'est un principe
général après et vous avez raison de le
souligner il se trouve qu'il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'actifs qui sont
déjà couverts et plutôt bien couverts
par des mécanismes existants et donc la
question ça va être pour ce mécanisme
bruxellois qui va vraiment être entre
guillemets visé par cette à mesure parce
que en France le développement des
renouvelables il est déjà complètement
j'allais dire bornée en terme de profit
pour le développeur puisque on a des CFD
les derniers CFD pour vous dire sur
l'éolien je crois qu'on était dans les
65 à me citer pas mais je crois que
c'est à peu près dans cette zone là 65
euros du mégawattheure
c'est c'est le cas c'est le CFD des
préfixes donc on voit bien que on est
disons en deçà des prix du marché et
donc que effectivement
le profit du producteur est protégé et
que l'État profite
d'une certaine manière d'une certaine
manne qui est le prix du marché donc là
il y a une redistribution qui est
naturelle structurelle et qui
aujourd'hui alors nous on n'a pas c'est
un petit peu compliqué en fait de mais
on ce qu'on sait c'est que pour l'État
on a parlé un des chiffres ont été cités
de revenus de l'ordre de 8 milliards sur
l'année qui vient de passer encore une
fois je sais pas si le chiffre est
exactement mais c'est de cette ordre de
grandeur et donc c'est significatif donc
le mécanisme existe déjà en France sur
les renouvelables et marche plutôt bien
sur l'hydro vous l'avez dit on a des
mécanismes qui marchent également très
très bien donc tout ça pour vous dire
c'est vrai que le mécanisme européen sur
ces mécanismes existants
je pense honnêtement serait redondant et
n'aurait pas forcément une efficacité
supplémentaire significative vous avez
noté que nos actifs en Belgique
également bénéficient d'une certaine
exposition au marché même si je vous le
rappelle bien sûr on couvre beaucoup les
volumes en avance donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup des volumes qu'on produit ne
sont pas vendus au prix spot mais à des
prix qui sont bien en dessous du prix
spot malgré ça il y a quand même une
certaine exposition au marché qui
explique partiellement et je l'ai dit
les résultats de l'année 2022 avec bien
sûr un bon taux de disponibilité et pour
ces activités là le gouvernement belge a
déjà mis en place un régime de taxation
qui est assez bien défini et qui nous
paraît entre guillemets
servir l'objectif d'une bonne
contribution et d'une bonne répartition
des profits de ces actifs là voilà donc
je pense que j'ai répondu à vos deux
questions est-ce que tu veux
répondre s'il te plaît à la question sur
la conversion cash flow et puis un petit
peu donner une vue effectivement un peu
plus historique que juste la comparaison
21 22 merci merci
dans ce qu'a dit Catherine il y a un
point qui est vraiment très important
c'est que la comme la plupart de nos
concurrents nous couvrons de manière
régulière les prises qui veut dire que
les prix que nous allons toucher dans
une année représente en fait une moyenne
des prix il y a deux ans il y a un an et
les prix de l'année en cours donc il y a
un effet roulant qui fait qu'il y a pas
de volatilité aussi forte que ce qu'on
pourrait penser simplement en appliquant
les prix de marché et ça c'est une on
fait tous et on le fait tous parce qu'on
a besoin de lisser à la volatilité c'est
c'est pénible pour tout le monde pour
tous nos clients mais c'est pénible pour
nous aussi vis-à-vis de nos banquiers
vis-à-vis de nos Mandans donc on est
obligé aussi de faire un effet de
lissage qui qui est une réalité
historique partagée par un sang du
marché alors vous avez effectivement on
a regardé peut-être pour construire sur
l'exemple de Catherine sur le résultat
net récurrent le résultat est récurrent
c'est vraiment l'agrégat clé qui est
donc le résultat qui sert de base à nos
dividendes qui sert de base à la
valorisation par les actionnaires c'est
vraiment l'agrégat de référence pour le
secteur c'est pas vrai de tous les
secteurs mais dans le secteur des ce
qu'on appelle les utilités c'est
vraiment l'agrégat de référence donc
c'était effectivement 2,9 en 2021 en
2020 c'était 1,7 donc effectivement on a
une amélioration forte de notre résultat
entre 2020 et 2022 et si on reprend les
blocs si on reprend les blocs de que
mentionner Catherine ce sont en gros les
mêmes alors simplement il y a beaucoup
plus sur le nucléaire en Belgique parce
que effectivement entre 2020 et 2022 il
y a un effet nucléaire qui est 50% plus
de 50% de la meilleure action des
résultats viennent du nucléaire belge la
raison c'est qu'en 2020 nous perdions de
l'argent
le nucléaire beige a perdu de l'argent
chez engie pendant des années donc il y
a eu effectivement un effet c'est une
position qui est alors contrairement au
renouvelable c'est une position qui est
beaucoup plus ouverte dans le marché et
donc avec les niveaux de prix électrique
qu'il y avait en Europe et notamment en
Belgique nous perdions de l'argent on a
perdu de l'argent pendant des années en
Belgique et c'est donc vous avez un
effet de rattrapage 2020-2022 qui est
très très spectaculaire et qui explique
la moitié de l'amélioration des
résultats entre 2020 et 2022 tel
qu'estimé évidemment c'est de réussir à
estimer puisque aujourd'hui une rue de
station pas sortie mais la moitié c'est
le nucléaire beige regardez ça l'ordre
de grandeur après sur le reste vous
allez retrouver les mêmes effets c'est à
dire la croissance du renouvelable la
mise en service de nouvelles
installations plus nos efforts de
productivité ça ça va faire en gros 20%
de l'amélioration du résultat cette fois
entre 2020 et 2022 le reste le troisième
bloc c'est effectivement les prix
d'énergie c'est du Forex des taux de
change puisqu'on a on a l'appréciation
de la monnaie brésilienne qui nous on a
des grosses activités au Brésil c'est
bien sûr de l'effet prix et c'est aussi
un effet de ressaut du covid puisque
2020 c'était quand même l'année du covid
donc on a un bout d'effet de covid pour
être tout à fait honnête c'est difficile
de le tracer dans la complexité des
organisations mais vous avez si vous
prenez le nucléaire c'est très clair
l'augmentation des renouvelables c'est
très facile la productivité c'est tracée
puisque ça on a des outils pour le tracé
et le reste qui effectivement
un effet cumulé de ces effets prises des
effets de change et d'effet covid qui
nous a fait le reste de notre
amélioration donc c'est ça vous
retrouvez quand même des grandes bases
de 2021 2022 vous les retrouvez sur 2022
2022 après vous venez je pense que vous
avez raison de regarder des séries un
tout petit peu plus longues
et sur la location effectivement de nos
profits je pense que je retiens en tout
cas ce que vous avez dit sur le taux de
marjonnette donc on vous rendra dans la
dans la copie dans les questions je
retiens que vous avez besoin d'une
analyse un peu de longue série de
marjenet donc je propose de le faire sur
éteindre récurrent on le fera donc on va
essayer de vous donner des éléments pour
que vous puissiez le pister sur un
certain nombre d'années après vous savez
dans une entreprise il y a des effets de
bord et des effets de sortie d'actifs il
y a des c'est pas les mêmes périmètres
mais on va on va faire le travail
essayer d'être le plus didactique
possible après sur le sujet des des
revenus et des profits de la location
qui je voudrais vous gardiez un chiffre
très simple qui va qui est assez
étourdissant en 2019 les achats
d'énergie représentaient 36% du total de
nos dépenses
Catherine l'a expliqué ça pas producteur
on achète de l'énergie on la transforme
où on la vend on achète du gaz on le
vend on achète du gaz on le transforme
en électricité c'est 36% en 2022 on
estime on est évidemment encore en cours
mais disons que sur la base des chiffres
à fin août c'est 71%
. donc vous prenez le total de nos
dépenses la part de l'achat d'énergie à
doubler en trois ans et 2019 c'est bien
c'est avant covid enfin voyez c'est
avant toutes les vibrations sur le prix
d'énergie ça vous donne une idée du
changement sismique qu'on a eu dans
notre propre constitution de coûts et
dans notre propre cash parce que
évidemment cet achat d'énergie c'est du
cash out c'est c'est des sorties de cash
flow c'est évidemment de l'énergie qu'on
est obligé d'acheter alors au Gazprom de
ce monde en grande partie mais pas que
et effectivement c'est là que vous voyez
le doublement de la part ce qui veut
dire que la part du reste que ce soit
d'ailleurs les frais de personnel les
dividendes tout ça effectivement a eu
tendance à baisser en relatif par
rapport à notre cash parce qu'on a été
entre guillemets manger il y a quand
même un poste qui a légèrement augmenté
c'est les taxes parce que effectivement
comme les taxes sont travaillées
directement sur la valeur de l'énergie
on a quand même un petit une petite
augmentation sur ce sujet là donc ça je
pense que on pourra vous revenir aussi
peut-être avec des éléments un petit peu
documentés mais vraiment le 36% en 1971%
en 2022 ça vous donne quand même une
idée de ce à quoi on fait face
juste une précision vous avez dit le
reste ça baisse et vous avez rajouté en
relatif notamment vous avez parlé des
dividendes et de la masse salariale ça
veut dire qu'on a absolu ça augmente
alors non pour le dividende il est à peu
près stable sur la période sauf en 2020
puisque il y en a pas eu donc année que
vide 0 dividendes je note Kenji était la
seule entreprise du secteur a coupé
totalement son dividende donc ça c'est
un point important sur la sur la masse
salariale alors vous avez en fait une
partie qui est en baisse mais qui est
liée à la sortie de de des coins donc
Catherine la mentionné donc une activité
importante qui est très très intense en
main d'oeuvre donc on a 74
000 salariés qui qui nous quittent et
donc on a un effet masse salarial par
rapport à 2019 qui réel mais évidemment
les salaires n'ont pas baissé un taux
qu'ils ont continué à augmenter on va
leur absolue
merci beaucoup du coup on va prendre les
questions des différents collègues
membres de la mission je sais pas qui
veut se lancer Marina Ferrari merci
RAL messieurs bonjour
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui alors on a
fait une on a regardé un peu en arrière
sur la période écoulée j'ai l'une de vos
interviews à la maîtrise générale où
vous aviez des inquiétudes des quant à
l'incertitude qui pèse justement sur
notamment le gaz russe et vous notiez
des baisses de consommation déjà de
certains clients notamment des ménages
et des entreprises avec des chiffres
quand même significatifs puisque vous
parliez de quelques pourcentages pour
les ménages et les PME mais des
pourcentages à deux chiffres notamment
dans l'industrie alors par rapport à
cela j'aimerais savoir si aujourd'hui
vous êtes en capacité j'imagine que
c'est très compliqué vu ce qui se passe
mais de nous donner une visibilité sur
vos activités à deux cinq ans
voire plus mais celle là ça me paraît
relever de la boule de cristal
alors oui c'est c'est vrai que
c'est assez compliqué de faire ses
projections de consommation
contenu des phénomènes presque de
discontinuité qu'on est en train de
vivre donc plusieurs sujets d'abord
il y a effectivement une certaine
élasticité c'est à dire une réponse
aussi au prix que l'on voit parmi nos
clients à la fois sur les particuliers
et sur les industriels c'est aussi une
réponse je crois aux appels de sobriété
qui ont été passées depuis un moment
donc il y a une partie de cette baisse
de demande c'est du positif il y a une
partie de cette baisse de demande qui
nous inquiète un petit peu on vous le
cache pas parce que en particulier sur
le tissu industriel et PME on voit bien
et on entend que certaines industries
sont en train de soit suspendre leur
production soit d'attendre les jours
meilleurs pour pouvoir
acheter de l'énergie à meilleur prix
donc il y a quand même un petit sujet là
qui est qui est une petite tissu
d'inquiétude vous cache pas après bien
sûr moi je suis une dirigeante
d'entreprise je suis forcément optimiste
et mon job et évidemment et c'est pour
ça que quand je parle d'accélération de
la transition énergétique j'ai vraiment
une conviction forte parce que je suis
vous avez moi quand je suis arrivée chez
engie un des experts d'engie est venu me
voir il m'a dit est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte on va peut-être vers un
monde où l'énergie ne coûtera plus rien
et c'était il y a exactement deux ans
c'était juste avant que j'arrive c'est
incroyable mais en fait quand vous
projetez à un monde avec beaucoup
d'énergie renouvelables avec du
nucléaire qui nous donne la bonne base
quoi qui avec du gaz des carboné qui
nous permet d'affronter les points avec
des capacités de stockage qui bien sûr
aide et complémente ce renouvelables
vous pouvez vous imaginer qu'en coût de
production vous avez finalement un
système en tout cas qui déjà dépend un
peu moins des autres et des intrants qui
robuste et qui potentiellement peut
effectivement devenir très bon marché
donc nous on a quand même cette
conviction qu'il faut y aller à fond
dans la transition énergétique sans
opposer sans opposer les technologies
aux autres je pense qu'il faut utiliser
cette crise pour se dire les débats de
anti machin de dire ça c'est bien ça
s'est pas bien il faut arrêter on voit
bien qu'il va falloir ne pas mettre tous
nos œufs dans le même panier il faut
qu'on diversifie le mix français bien
sûr s'occuper du nucléaire mais
également des autres et donc moi ma
conviction c'est qu'il faut accélérer et
qu'il faut travailler sur cette
transition énergétique pour pouvoir
avoir la décarbonation hyper important
parce qu'on voit bien quand même que le
réchauffement climatique a des effets
absolument délétères sur nos modes de
vie l'économie enfin tout quoi et
évidemment sur aussi l'aspect cool
énergie et indépendance énergétique donc
il faut
merci de votre présence alors je suis un
peu pour vous dire un peu scotché de ce
que je viens d'entendre sur la question
de l'énergie qui nous coûtent rien
notamment quand on parle du nucléaire et
notamment quand on parle du coup des
investissements du nucléaire et du coup
de la traite de la question de
traitement des déchets qui nous entraîne
sur des coûts environnementaux je ne
parle que de cela mais aussi des coûts
pour des centaines des centaines
millions d'années donc bon j'avoue que
je partage pas du tout la réflexion qui
vous a été faite que vous rapportiez
j'espère comme une simple anecdote à
laquelle vous n'adhérez pas j'imagine
donc moi je voulais vous poser plusieurs
questions notamment par rapport à ce que
vous aviez dit Monsieur sur la question
du lissage des prix
je comprends bien effectivement pourquoi
vous le mettez en place et ce à quoi ça
vous garantit mais quels sont ces
pratiques là comment vous arrivez à le
faire sur plusieurs années
et vous dites vous me disiez que
l'ensemble du marché pratiquait de cette
façon là et comment vous arrivez à
faire ce lissage j'ai une petite
interrogation là dessus et puis ensuite
vous nous avez indiqué que
2019-2022 de votre souvenir de deux
chiffres importants effectivement achat
d'énergie 36% de votre chiffre
d'affaires 36% de vos dépenses 36% de
quoi 71% en 2022 et donc si vous pouviez
nous donner en 2019 en 2022 combien ça a
rapporté la vente puisque vous faites de
la vente de cette énergie que vous avez
acheté combien par rapport à votre
chiffre d'affaires ou par rapport à je
ne sais plus quel critère que vous aviez
pris pour nous faire c'est pourcentage
parce qu'en fait 36 et 71 si vous avez
répercuté le coût au moment de la
revente finalement pour vous ça ne
change pas grand chose même si ça change
beaucoup pour le consommateur final qui
est le particulier ou l'entreprise
et puis en dernier lieu j'avais une
petite question concernant les 170000
collaborateurs dans le monde dont 70000
en France où sont les autres et quels
sont les selon quelles organisation par
rapport à la société mère qui est en
France
merci
alors un mot sur le lissage est pris
d'énergie sans être trop pédant donc
il y a un marché qui est relativement
profond en Europe de ce qu'on appelle
les forwards c'est à dire des ventes à
terme donc quand on achète ou qu'on
vende l'énergie on peut le fait sur le
marché du spot c'est à dire une
transaction immédiate un peu comme c'est
on va n'importe quel commerce on fait
une transaction on achète et on est
livré immédiatement et puis on peut
faire de la vente à terre cette vente à
terre ou cet achat à terme permet
d'aller sur des cours historiquement qui
allaient sur un an deux ans trois ans et
puis on va se rapprocher de du terme
plus on va se limiter dans le temps donc
quand aujourd'hui si on traite du 2025
on traite l'année calendaire 2025 quand
on va se rapprocher 2025 on pourra
commencer à travailler le trimestre puis
le mois puis le jour puis à un moment on
va s'approcher très très proche pour le
faire même sur des granularités infras
quotidiennes pourquoi parce que ce sont
ces systèmes de vente à terme qui
permettent à tout le monde d'équilibrer
aussi puisque tout le monde a envie
d'avoir de la visibilité alors nous on
le fait pour des raisons que je vous
indiquais qui est d'avoir une stabilité
donc on fait ces ventes à terme on le
fait aussi pour nos clients puisque nos
clients souhaitent aussi avoir de la
stabilité donc quand il se tourne vers
engie ils nous disent engie je voudrais
acheter voilà je voudrais un contrat par
lequel pendant trois ans j'ai une
fourniture d'électricité c'est vrai même
des particuliers qui vont avoir le choix
sur un an deux ans trois ans et en
général on veut du prix fixe on veut
savoir ce qu'on va payer c'est le cas
aussi la plupart des entreprises pour
faire ça on est obligé de nous-mêmes de
nous couvrir dans le marché donc on a
notre propre production on est capable
de la vendre à terme en la vendant un
terme on a sécurisé le produit et on est
capable de former un prix pour le client
donc tout ce travail que vous voyez
certainement d'ailleurs vous-même quand
vous vous avez vos propres factures à
prix fixes vous imaginez que derrière il
y a une mécanique considérable et que la
production elle elle va arriver quand
elle va arriver elle sera vendue au prix
spot et donc tous ces systèmes de
couverture existent pour permettre aux
clients d'avoir une possibilités sur
leurs factures énergétiques la plus
longue possible aujourd'hui ce marché
est sous pression c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui on manque de liquidité pour
traiter à 3 ans à deux ans c'est-à-dire
que l'angoisse des producteurs de
l'électricité tellement forte qui ne
veulent plus vendre sur les échéances
longues puisque personne ne veut se
retrouver avant sur des échéances et se
retrouver en risque de pas pouvoir
livrer parce que si on peut pas livrer
et qu'on a vendu il faut se racheter sur
le marché c'est ce que disait Catherine
sur le cargo de GNL qu'on a eu mais ça
on peut le faire sur des volumes
beaucoup plus gros en électricité et là
ça peut coûter très très cher donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe aujourd'hui les
gens sont très prudents comme les gens
ne sont plus à la vente bah les prix
montent et donc vous avez effectivement
sur le marché à terme aujourd'hui des
prix vous avez certainement vu des
articles de presse on parlait de prix
astronomiques à 1000 euros du
mégawattheure 3500 euros en Allemagne
c'est le résultat de ce squeeze de
d'écrasement de marché
qui ne permet plus d'avoir la liquidité
donc c'est ces actions de lissage c'est
ça a été créé au fil du temps par le
marché européen pour donner aux acteurs
économiques la possibilité d'avoir une
visibilité de leur prix énergie qui soit
industrielle qui soit particuliers et
les opérateurs que nous sommes nous
sommes des contributeurs importants à ce
lissage et on l'utilise aussi pour nous
clairement pour pouvoir lisser nos
résultats et aussi s'engager avec des
ste-collurs qui sont très importants
donc ça c'est je pense que j'espère
avoir été à peu près clair
alors aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de faire ses couvertures
effectivement il y a même des produits
qui sont pratiquement indisponibles sur
lesquels on peut plus on peut plus faire
de couverture on est obligé de rester ce
qu'on appelle ouvert c'est-à-dire en
risque parce qu'on peut plus le marché
n'est pas là pour pour faire ses
couvertures bon ça c'est
alors voilà exactement donc Catherine me
le rappelle sur ça qu'aujourd'hui on
transpire à grosses gouttes pour pouvoir
offrir à nos clients simplement offrir à
nos clients une visibilité parce que je
pense que nous tous j'ai pris mon
contrat engie en décembre voilà j'ai
acheté du 2 ans et pendant deux ans je
sais ce que je paye mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est pas évident pour nous
de sourcer à un prix correct à un prix
correct de sourcer deux ans parce que
aujourd'hui quand on se retourne dans le
marché vous avez vu les prix sont ils
sont très très élevés est-ce qu'on a
envie d'engager les gens sur des prix de
cette nature c'est quand même un vrai
problème objectif effectivement il y a
une part de de marché c'est un peu
affolé donc aujourd'hui c'est quand même
très difficile donc on a ce lissage
c'est l'intérêt de tous et il existe
depuis longtemps maintenant il est il
est effectivement sous pression alors
vous disiez mais ces achats d'énergie
vous les avez récupéré globalement oui
globalement oui notre métier n'est pas
d'acheter de l'énergie cher pour la
revendre pas chère sinon ça va pas durer
longtemps donc c'est le directeur
financier qui parle évidemment le
directeur général peut me taper sur la
tête mais non il faut le faire on on
fera pas longtemps parce que notre
métier c'est pas celui-là notre métier
n'a jamais le gaz on n'invente pas le
Power enfin l'électricité on la produit
à partir d'un train et c'est intrants on
est obligé de se les procurer donc vous
avez raison notre chiffre d'affaires a
augmenté a dû bien sûr à du concurrence
et c'est voilà c'est ce que disait
Catherine ça aujourd'hui on cherche les
solutions c'est qu'on se rend bien
compte que l'énergie qu'on achète encore
une fois on n'a pas une chambre magique
dans laquelle on la crée bah on l'a
pousse derrière à nos clients et on les
met en difficulté gardez en tête que
l'intérêt d'énergie c'est de garder ses
clients la dernière chose que nous
voulons c'est de détruire nos clients
parce que la destruction de demande dont
vous parliez pour nous c'est pas une
très bonne nouvelle hein donc on a quand
même intérêt à chaque fois à
solvabiliser la demande et à trouver des
solutions pour garder les clients en
particulier les clients industriels et
les clients de l'entreprise qui eux
peuvent disparaître les particuliers
encore en Espagne ils peuvent
disparaître donc ça il y a des vrais
sujets pour nous donc on retrouve bien
ces 36%
sur son revenu dans le chiffre
d'affaires vous avez raison tout à fait
non mais c'est évident et dans notre
chiffre d'affaires il augmente il
reflète effectivement cette hausse des
prix
j'en suis Tanguy Xavier une question
les emplois alors on a deux pays phares
hors France et la Belgique et le Brésil
où nous avons une forte représentation
de nos effectifs et puis ensuite dans
quelques pays européens l'Allemagne
l'Espagne l'Italie en Amérique latine
Chili et le Pérou le Mexique les
États-Unis
enfin quelques quelques entités au
Moyen-Orient particulièrement Arabie
Saoudite et Émirats arabes unis et enfin
en Asie Singapour et Australie
principalement alors évidemment je suis
pas complètement exhaustive mais ça vous
donne une idée un peu de notre empreinte
géographique et pardon j'ai oublié
l'Afrique ou nous sommes présents
également en Afrique du Nord et surtout
en Afrique du Sud le pays Afrique du Sud
et merci Monsieur le corps rapporteur
bonjour merci pour votre présence je
vais rebondir aussi sur l'anecdote que
vous avez donné sur le fait que
l'énergie vient tout ne coûterait plus
rien mais
ne prenez pas mal mais je doute qu'une
entreprise comme Elie souhaite que
l'énergie ne coûte plus rien votre
métier d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on vous
demande c'est de gagner de l'argent
c'est le but d'une entreprise vous
n'êtes pas une ONG et moi je pense que
c'est mieux quand les rôles sont clairs
et vous ne pas vous apprendre votre
métier mais en 2012 l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie il y avait
déclaré que nous allons entrer dans un
âge d'or du gaz c'est elle dort du gaz
il a plusieurs origines la première
origine c'est la transition pour sortir
du charbon on peut s'en féliciter mais
la France est sortie de charbon par le
nucléaire et pas par le développement
des EnR et du gaz et vous au contraire
vous pensez qu'il faut sortir des
énergies la plus polluante le charbon en
continuant à utiliser du gaz et
notamment par le développement des EnR
qui sauf si vous avez une solution
technique à court terme avec laquelle
que vous voulez partager avec nous
aujourd'hui le backup à échelle humaine
en tout cas de ce que nous verrons vous
et moi de notre vivant
contrat du backup gazier je n'ai pas
connaissance aujourd'hui de technologie
mature qui puisse remplacer le backup
casier quand le il y a un anticyclone
sur toute l'Europe et que l'éolien et le
solaire s'effondre l'hiver donc si vous
avez une autre solution n'est pas
connaissance donc vous allez continuer à
vendre du gaz et c'est votre métier je
ne vous reproche pas ce que je vous
reproche par contre c'est peut-être de
ne pas dire toute la vérité quand vous
vendez des ENR à savoir que les EnR ne
peuvent vivre aujourd'hui que avec le
gaz ce faisant vous avez un intérêt à ce
que le prix de marché augmente puisque
si le prix marqué s'effondre au moyen de
production ne sont pas performants et ne
sont pas rentables à ce titre vous dites
que vous avez perdu de l'argent sur le
nucléaire mais de j'ai cru comprendre
que le nucléaire était vos pertes en
Belgique étaient essentiellement dû à
des dépréciations et que si vous faisiez
des dépréciations vous continuez à
toucher des dividendes les trucs cru
croire que l'année dernière en 2021 vous
avez en 2020 pardon vous avez une perte
de dépréciation mais vous avez quand
même un une un royalty un dividende
versé de 700 millions d'euros
parallèlement donc d'un côté vous avez
perdu de l'argent dans les comptes
effectivement vous en avez quand même
gagné en termes de trésorerie donc
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer
pourquoi vous avez dit que vous avez
perdu de l'argent alors que c'est pas
aussi simple que ça vous avez aussi des
volants de soutenu un désengagement du
nucléaire en tout cas votre prédécesseur
madame McGregor n'a jamais défendu
ardemment le nucléaire ou peut-être nous
expliquer pourquoi vous êtes sortis de
deux grands projets un projet au
Royaume-Uni c'est sûr un produit en
Turquie j'ai pas trop trouvé
d'informations comment ça s'était fini
donc vous avez volontairement
abandonné des projets sans émission de
carbone pour sans doute vendre des
projets avec une mission de carbone de
la même manière en Belgique vous avez
vous n'avez pas défendu le maintien
encore aujourd'hui vous résistez au
maintien de réacteurs nucléaires pour
des raisons peut-être comptable qui vous
appartiennent mais qui ne sont pas
d'intérêt général et au contraire vous
avez investi dans des moyens des
centrales à gaz et sauf erreur c'est
centrale j'aimerais savoir quelle est
leur l'évolution de leur rentabilité
depuis trois ans
et enfin donc pour revenir ma première
question ce sera tout ma première vous
vous êtes des experts du marché du gaz
comme vous le savez le marché du gaz a
commencé à augmenter avant avant la la
guerre en Ukraine pardon et
tendentiellement vous saviez que c'était
le cas vous saviez que le gaz naturel
coûte plus cher à produire et à exporter
que le gazon pipeline vous le saviez
donc pourquoi n'avez-vous pas dit aux
Français et aux experts à ceux à qui
vous avez conseillé de développer les
eurs et le gaz que ton anciennement le
gaz à l'écouter plus clair puisque le
GNL dont on a besoin est plus clair que
le gaz traditionnel
alors beaucoup de questions et je vais
peut-être commencer par réagir sur la
place du gaz dans le mix énergétique tel
que on l'imagine
à l'avenir je veux qualifier l'anecdote
que j'ai cité tout à l'heure pour dire
que c'est évidemment pas ma vue que
l'énergie ne coûtera rien on voit bien
que aujourd'hui on a des défis énormes
d'investissement dans cette transition
énergétique ces investissements vont
devoir avoir un retour et donc
évidemment l'énergie sera pas gratuite
d'ici là mais je trouvais que c'était
intéressant de voir à quel point la
perspective et le regard sur l'énergie
pouvait changer en si peu de temps donc
je ferme la parenthèse la place du gaz
alors je pense qu'il faut surtout pas
opposer le gaz et les énergies
renouvelables nous notre conviction
c'est de dire que un monde où on
électrifié tous les usages n'est pas un
monde réaliste
où nous aurons des énergies qui seront
disponibles et à coût accessibles
pourquoi si vous regardez aujourd'hui en
France le réseau gazier un soir d'hiver
fournit environ une capacité de 150 GW
le réseau électrique français c'est
environ 100 GW donc si vous voulez dire
qu'on ne veut plus de gaz en France il
faut plus que doubler l'infrastructure
électrique en France ce qui n'est juste
pas possible et ça c'est avant de se
dire qu'on électrifie toute la mobilité
donc le point c'est bien sûr qu'il faut
électrifier le plus possible les usages
mais c'est une
utopie que de dire on va électrifier
tous les usages et qu'on va avoir besoin
de gaz pendant encore très très
longtemps c'est vrai que nous avons
cette conviction chez engie nous pensons
aussi parce que nous avons les
engagements très forts en 2045
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone donc
nous pensons aussi qu'il ne faut pas que
se reposer sur le gaz naturel et qu'en
fait il faut trouver de la substitution
d'où la décarmation du gaz naturel avec
quelle solution des solutions qui
existent aujourd'hui déjà qui sont déjà
assez mûres le biométhane aujourd'hui
qu'on arrive à produire avec des coûts
de production entre 80 et 100 euros du
mégawattheure donc aujourd'hui sans
subvention compétitif par rapport au
prix du marché quand même il faut le
dire et puis des dérivés d'hydrogène de
lit méthane et effectivement des
solutions qui seront qui sont encore
aujourd'hui pas complètement mature je
dis pas que tout est gagné mais nous on
a vraiment une vision il y a deux choses
en fait il y a que le gaz à cause de ses
propriétés physiques de l'infrastructure
qui existe va faire partie pendant très
très longtemps du mix énergétique
français ça c'est une conviction la
meilleure infrastructure c'est celle qui
existe déjà or la France a la chance
d'avoir de superbes infrastructures
qu'il faut réutiliser donc
honnêtement on ne pourra pas faire sans
le gaz c'est pas vrai par contre dès
carbonne-le et c'est pour ça que nous
quand on réfléchit avec les régulateurs
les élus etc c'est biométhane à fond
parce que c'est aujourd'hui la même
molécule c'est du web on peut vraiment
le remplacer donc il faut y aller à fond
biométal et puis le méthane de synthèse
qu'on va pouvoir synthétiser à partir de
l'hydrogène etc qui va nous permettre de
réutiliser toute cette infrastructures
qui est déjà amorti qui existe déjà et
bien sûr consacrer l'électrification qui
est très importante aux usages pour
lesquels on n'a pas le choix comment on
va faire la mobilité électrique il faut
bien
continuer à travailler sur notre réseau
électrique et sur nos capacités donc ça
c'est très important donc nous on pense
que le gaz va jouer un rôle très
important et d'ailleurs quand je dis
nous on n'est pas les seuls le scénario
RTE sur lequel est basé la décision de
construire 6 EPR bien sûr inclut une
portion très importante de gaz donc
c'est pas juste engie qui est pas là
parce que vous pouvez accusé d'être
biaisé vous auriez raison c'est vrai
qu'on est biaisé c'est normal on vient
de Gaz de France mais RTE le dit qu'on
va avoir besoin de gaz donc ça c'est la
réalité du mix énergétique français et
ça il faut qu'on travaille là-dessus
donc je pense que honnêtement c'est
quand même important qu'on se dise bon
il y a les choses il faut on peut facile
c'est comme ça quoi et donc par contre
sur l'électrique nous ce qu'on dit c'est
quoi c'est qu'il faut chaque terawater
compte chaque mégawattheure compte et
donc il faut construire et développer
des renouvelables qui quand elle
produisent produisent de manière très
significative vous savez très bien alors
c'est vrai qu'à l'intermittence mais
l'intermittence on peut bien sûr en
combinant les technologies avec parfois
du gaz du nucléaire la complémentarité
solaire éolien et bien sûr des
technologies de stockage qui existent on
commence déjà aujourd'hui avoir des
technologies de batterie nous on est en
train de construire des énormes
batteries en Australie pour justement
aider à stabiliser le réseau et c'est
des solutions qui aujourd'hui
tendance à être si c'est vrai
aujourd'hui on en a pas beaucoup en
France mais elle pour elles feront
partie du mix ça va pas être la seule
solution et bien sûr qu'on aura besoin
du nucléaire et probablement qu'on
continuera à avoir besoin d'un petit peu
de production électrique à partir du gaz
c'est pour ça qu'il faut le décarboner
le gaz etc mais donc nous notre point
c'est que en fait il faut surtout faire
des faire des investissements qui sont
sans regret et aujourd'hui si on
investissait pas dans les énergies
renouvelables on aurait beaucoup de
regrets à mon avis ce qui veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas investir dans le
nucléaire pas du tout pas du tout
on le fait déjà
bon alors pardon je suis longue mais
vous avez compris que c'est un sujet qui
me passionne et je pense que non mais
c'est vraiment une discussion importante
parce que il y a quand même des fausses
idées et alors ensuite vous m'avez posé
une question sur engie et notre rôle
dans nucléaire alors engie a fait des
choix nous on pense qu'on peut pas tout
faire le nucléaire c'est compliqué c'est
un métier c'est aussi des risques
significatifs vous avez parlé du passif
nucléaire la gestion des déchets
aujourd'hui engie porte environ 14
milliards d'euros pour
pour nos engagements du liés au passif
du nucléaire en Belgique donc c'est
vraiment des montants significatifs
aujourd'hui nous avons décidé en ligne
avec la décision belge qui avait été
prise bien sûr d'arrêter nuclé en 2025
de ne plus opérer nucléaire et donc
cette décision elle était prise bon je
trouve qu'elle est assez cohérente avec
le fait que engie a énormément de choses
à faire aujourd'hui dans ces métiers que
je viens de rappeler et de décrire et en
revanche qu'il y a évidemment besoin
d'acteurs nucléaires qui sont concentrés
sur le nucléaire parce qu'il y a
beaucoup pas faire moi je crois tout
simplement un petit peu que chacun son
métier ça veut pas dire que nous sommes
anti-nucléaire
effectivement on a cette année touché
700 millions de dividendes je pas été
j'ai pas fait mystère de l'amélioration
des résultats substantiels de 2021 mais
je tiens aussi à noter que pendant des
années il y a eu zéro dividende de la
part d'électrabel alors même qu'elle est
crevette ne tient pas seulement le
nucléaire belge mais c'est aussi une
holding très importante de nos activités
internationales donc il y a de
nombreuses activités internationales par
exemple notre joyau brésiliens qui est
en fait détenu par Electrabel et donc
elle est travaille pendant des années à
payer aucun dividende à engie alors que
par ailleurs et d'autres activités qui
est généré beaucoup de flux qui
arrivaient chez Electrabel donc il y a
vraiment aucun problème vous pourrez
assez facilement voir que même au niveau
du résultat opérationnel on a été en
perte sur le nucléaire pendant des
années c'est dans notre toutes nos
communications c'est très récent
effectivement on peut se à nouveau payer
du dividende sur Electrabel
parce que il y a d'autres activités que
le nucléaire au sein d'Electrabel
ah bah c'est parce que il y a un prix de
marché il y a un coût il faut savoir
quand même que en 2000 en 2017 2018 il y
a eu alors j'étais pas là mais il y a
une grave crise du nucléaire en Belgique
des corrosion des microfissures ont été
identifiés il a fallu dépenser
énormément d'argent pour régler ses
problèmes j'espère que ça ne fait pas
écho autre chose mais donc micro
fissures corrosion il a fallu arrêter
les centrales ont été downs ont été à
l'arrêt pendant des années on avait des
taux de disponibilités centrales qui
étaient très bas on a il faut savoir que
la vraie la raison pour laquelle 2020
2021 a augmenté c'est que nos taux de
disponibilités centrales sont passées là
je parle de mémoire lors de 40% à 80%
donc c'est ce 90% donc là les centrales
deviennent disponibles mais quand la
centrale n'est pas disponible ça coûte
très très cher le nucléaire parce que
vous avez tous les coups d'opération qui
sont qui sont présents et on a transpiré
en 2017 en 2018 en 2019 en 2020 parce
qu'on nos machines ne tournait pas et
donc là vous perdez beaucoup d'argent
mais vraiment beaucoup
oui on arrive à la fin de on arrive à la
alors il y a la question de la
rentabilité des centrales à gaz
peut-être que ça va
on enchaîne nos questions pour vous
laisser un mode conclusion pour qu'on
arrive à la fin
il y a plein de sujets qui sont abordés
et sans doute sont tous très
intéressants mais je serai revenir sur
le périmètre de la mission y compris
vous avez dit RTE bon il y a plusieurs
scénarios derrière toi bref ça
nécessiterait un débat à part
je me permets de revenir quand même sur
une question toute très simple très
concrète
vous avez donné différents chiffres les
achats d'énergie etc moi ce qui
m'intéresse à la fin c'est le résultat
net que vous avez réalisé puisque c'est
le périmètre de notre mission et est-ce
que vous confirmez que du point de vue
de l'évolution
2021-2022 moi je parle premier semestre
parce que le reste c'est des estimations
pour l'instant vous êtes passé d'un
résultat net de 2,3 milliards en premier
semestre 2021 à 5 milliards au semestre
2022 c'est une augmentation de 117%
est-ce que vous le confirmez
premièrement deuxièmement est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire comment
se bénéfice se répartit entre les
activités liées au gaz et les activités
liées à l'électricité et troisième
élément c'est plutôt dans une
caractérisation politique ou de votre
vision est-ce que vous considérez que
une hausse de cette nature est une
hausse exceptionnelle extraordinaire ou
un super profit merci j'avais une
dernière question aussi comme ça vous
pourrez répondre à l'ensemble puisque la
question qui nous préoccupe est au moins
autant le montant des profits selon leur
les différents agrégats comptables qu'on
peut choisir pour les mesurer que leur
utilisation et vous aviez cité dans
votre propos introductif le fait d'avoir
un investissement de 30 milliards
environ dans la transition écologue
enfin 30 milliards d'euros
d'investissement dont la moitié vous
disiez en grande partie dans la
transition écologique je voulais savoir
si on pouvait avoir des éléments un peu
plus précis sur ces investissements
notamment pour savoir comment il se
comparer à la trajectoire
d'investissement précédente puisque vous
comprenez derrière ce que je cherche à
comprendre c'est de savoir à quel point
la période un peu exceptionnelle que
nous traversons à tous les points de vue
peut permettre d'accélérer dans la
transition écologique pour les années à
venir
oui on vous donnera bien sûr le détail
mais
clairement fléchage prioritaire
transition énergétique et puis pas mal
d'investissements de maintenance pour
bien sûr maintenir notre outil
industriel qui est au cœur de des enjeux
d'Asie évidemment
rapidement sur la rentabilité des
centrales à gaz pour la si vous pensez
aux nouvelles centrales à gaz en
Belgique qui sont en cours de
construction pour aider la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de la Belgique qui a
été évidemment qui est mis sous tension
comme comme dans plusieurs pays
européens c'est une rentabilité qui en
fait assez prévisible puisque on a des
contrats pour la capacité donc en fait
c'est des rendements qui sont quasiment
assurés donc là il y a pas du tout
d'effet d'aubaines et des faits de
marché et je dirais pour peut-être en
réponse à la question sur les sur les
sur profits moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire la distinction entre une
variation
des résultats d'une activité d'une
entreprise qui évidemment d'une année à
l'autre peut-être perçue il y a des
années qui sont meilleurs que d'autres
et donc on a une variation
pour la définition des surprofiches
parce que c'est vraiment un débat assez
philosophique mais moi quand je
réfléchis je me dis bon sur profit il y
a si j'ai vraiment une activité dont le
coût n'a pas changé et dont le chiffre
d'affaires est multiplié par 5 ou par 10
là on peut se demander est-ce que il y a
pas un profit qui est effectivement
peut-être excessif et donc quand on
regarde chez engie nous quelles sont les
actifs qui répondent à cette
secrétaires-là
on vous en a parlé on a le nucléaire en
Belgique dont une grande partie est déjà
couverte donc vraiment on parle des
volumes qui sont pas encore couverts et
ceux-là effectivement bénéficie d'une
exposition au marché et donc de cette
manne peut-être qu'on pourrait appeler
ça sur profit mais et déjà taxé de
manière très importante et on vous
donnera bien sûr les chiffres par le
système belge de même on a nos actifs
hydro en France et là pareil on vous a
expliqué déjà il y a une couverture donc
on n'a pas on capture pas les prix spots
mais même si on n'avait pas cette
couverture ici on a une certaine
exposition au marché on a ces mécanismes
qui sont mis en place c'est pour ça que
pour engie même si c'est vrai que 2022
est une bonne année vous l'avez souligné
on est on est content et on est fier de
ce que les équipes ont fait franchement
ils ont fait un travail formidable on
était hyper exposé sur ces volumes gaz
russes on a fait un travail assez
spectaculaire à la fois sur le plan
physique pour assurer la sécurité
d'appro pour aujourd'hui être pas loin
de 100% de stockage pour diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement et on n'a
pas parlé de l'aspect opérationnel de
nos infras parce que les gens ont quand
même travaillé jour et nuit pour
s'assurer que nos terminaux
d'importation travaillait au maximum de
leur capacité pour pouvoir importer tout
ce gaz naturel qui est fait pour
contribuer à l'équilibre énergétique de
l'Europe donc on a fait tout ce travail
et donc plutôt une certaine fierté vous
allez dire voilà je m'arrête
oui mais là honnêtement elle travaille
tout le temps mais là il y a eu un
travail enfin on était en gestion de
crise franchement c'est et donc je pense
que c'est pas mal aussi de reconnaître
le travail qui a été fait vous avez posé
une question précise sur les chiffres 2
3 5 donc ces chiffres 2 3 5 sont exact
c'est le résultat net je vous invite
vraiment quand vous voulez mesurer la
performance DJ à utiliser le résultat
net récurrent parce qu'il exttourne un
certain nombre d'écriture qui sont des
écritures de
IFRS que je vais pas rentrer et qui sont
quand même très complexes c'est la base
du dividende donc vous pouvez dire que
le résultat est récurrent a priori est
quand même l'agrégat sur lequel il faut
se concentrer et après on peut regarder
une moitié d'année mais enfin je pense
que il y a une année vous savez que il y
a d'assaisonnalité dans nos activités
par définition c'est une saison de
chauffe et une saison de pas chauffe et
c'est dans l'air de rien mais c'est
juste monstrueux chez engie et je pense
que vous pouvez si vous regardez l'année
2021 les chiffres sont publics alors on
peut pas vous donner 2022 mais on donne
une projection de résultat net donc vous
imaginez bien que tu as aussi c'est des
choses sérieuses qu'on prend très au
sérieux je vous donne quand une idée et
ça vous donne une idée de la magnitude
de l'accroissement et la magnitude de
l'accroissement c'est de 9 versus ce que
disait Catherine une augmentation sonore
notre fourchette qui va être de 900
millions à milliers et demi donc
l'augmentation d'une année sur l'autre
c'est ça c'est 900 millions et demi si
vous prenez les chiffres que nous avons
confirmé au cours du mois de juillet ces
derniers chiffres disponibles donc ça
vous donne une idée effectivement de la
progression du résultat annuel qui est
quand même enfin qui est quand même
l'élément pertinent
bien merci beaucoup pour ces échanges et
ses éclairages